I would describe my day as cumbersome
crushing inflated astronomical
overwhelming its negative I'm chained to
something for the rest of my life I have
a total of $28,000 in state I did I have
nothing to show for my degree I have
nothing but a huge amount of debt I have
around $30,000 worth of stone in it it's
kind of like a dark cloud that hangs
over you I currently have probably right
around 180 thousand dollars I have a law
degree but I am NOT currently using it
two hundred and eighty thousand dollars
in student debt and by the time I finish
I'll be at about three hundred thousand
dollars it brings up a lot of shame yeah
it's it's hard to talk about excuse me
because it's I should have known better
but what I knew is I really wanted an
education I have a 17 year old she'll be
starting school soon I'll need to borrow
for her will I ever get married what
would it mean in partnership I wanted to
study being a medical assistant I really
enjoyed helping people it's it really
takes a toll it on everything you know I
don't want to share with people like a
lot it did sorry it's a
it's discouraging and some beer it's
embarrassing yeah I'm 22 I guess I don't
have that what you did I'm the first
person for my for my family to go to
college and I don't have anything to
show for it
I currently have 81 thousand dollars in
debt I didn't end up finishing my degree
when I did get loans they were never
enough to cover rent and food and school
because the school cost so much money
itself I ended up sleeping it out of my
car which made it much much more
difficult for me to do anything at all
education with stress to me from as
early as I can remember like you know my
parents are both immigrants to this
country so for them getting a college
education is like the Holy Grail I do
not think that education is worth it I
think nowadays you can teach yourself a
lot of things just from the internet in
YouTube I don't think that he knew the
full weight of what I was getting into
the smoothness of the financial aid
office the sort of crisp cleanliness and
the efficiency of it didn't leave a lot
of space for me to think about what I
was doing when I was living on student
loans I saved all of my receipts then I
cast them in bronze it's almost like as
if my debt is like this little weapon
this is a debt rock and so I feel like
you know it's something that could be
thrown it's also something that
potentially could be worth money
it says that it'll take until 2036 to
pay off my loan it would probably take
30 years and that 180 would end up
turning into probably 250 275 at the end
of the life term I've seen estimates
anywhere from four years if I sell my
soul and work crazy hours and make a lot
of money or if it's a little bit more
sane path it might be 8 to 10 years I
would pay as much as I need to pay to
keep my credit like not completely
I already have anxiety and it
certainly doesn't help I feel like I
missed out on being able to almost
achieve like the quote unquote American
dream
you